a good life is the fruit of a succession
of good decisions especially around love
and work
however we seldom accord to the business
of decision-making the kind of careful
attention it requires when faced with a
large decision we lack rituals and
procedures we typically procrastinate
lean on the nearest person or rush
headlong into an unexamined solution
fortunately decision-making is a skill
and like any other it can be taught the
chief enemy of good decisions is a lack
of sufficient perspectives on a problem
we should systematically think through
any issue from five distinct angles
through the eyes of variously our enemy
our gut death caution and courage as we
try out juggle with and then synthesize
these oblique perspectives we will feel
our sense of possibility expand and a
tolerable way forward gradually emerge
from the present confusion our enemies
have deep insights into us they know our
frailties they actively want the worst
for us and they're bringing a desperate
mean intelligence to bear on our case
thinking of them helps beautifully to
clarify our thoughts it can be
unfeasibly hard to be a true friend to
ourselves in the way we should be our
minds may well go blank if asked to
imagine what a sweet and well-meaning
person might advise us to do next with
so much better at getting into the heads
for bitterest foes they appreciate our
weaknesses and temptations like no other
we can at last put these characters to
constructive use by doing the very
opposite of what we suspect probably
very correctly they might propose and
say we will be energized and focused by
the haunting voices of those dispiriting
but very telling and mesmerizing judges
those who refuse to believe in us
in a sense we know the arts are already
or at least one version of it we call it
gut instinct and it's there from the
moment a dilemma first appears the gut
is the accumulation of all the decision
making lessons we've ever derived across
our lives revealed and consciously at
speed most of us have become rather good
at not listening to the gut probably it
got us into trouble a number of times
maybe pushing us into some crazy moments
so which we paid dear so now we pride
ourselves on being thinking people who
take their time gather evidence and make
full use of their higher mental powers
as well we should nevertheless we
thereby lose a source of important
insight we should be brave enough to
invite our gut to the decision-making
table not necessarily in order to follow
it but in order to know what it wants
and then submit it stubborn and
impatient certainties to gentle rational
cross-examination the largest but always
easily forgotten certainty is that all
our decisions are unfolding in the
backdrop of a giant ticking death clock
we should listen to its beat and take
its daunting messages to heart the
thought of death has a habit of
highlighting our responsibilities to
ourselves and of weakening our concern
for living according to what's expected
of us by society it's a terrifying agent
of authenticity death may lend us a
perverse new sort of confidence to
tackle challenges by frightening us
about one enormous thing it may make us
less scared of the many smaller
obstacles in our way our lives won't be
what they could be unless we submit
pretty much every choice we face to the
arbiter of eternity and oblivion
somewhere around the table at every
decision must be the voice of caution it
wears doughty clothes and speaks quietly
it certainly lacks glamour in an age of
bravado and bombast it's easy to feel
that we must always and invariably jump
because life has to be about giving the
new ago but it may not be let's remember
caution clears its throat to tell us
that most new businesses fail most
schemes end in disaster
and most future relationships will
merely rehash the themes of the current
unsatisfactory one furthermore there's a
huge amount to be lost and there are
many people around us who make it very
hurt by our ambitions the devil one
knows may just have the edge over the
many demons one doesn't quite caution
doesn't look down on the idea of
compromise it recognizes that there are
at points simply no ideal options for
the imperfect beings we ultimately are
caution has the bravery not always to
try to rebel the best reality from an
early age we've learned how to follow
the rules wait in line and do the
dutiful expected things we can be good
boys and girls it got us to where we are
today there would have been no other way
to learn how to spell drive a car or
take up a position in the working world
but there can now be a subtle risk from
an opposite direction the risk of being
overly faithful for too long to
conventions that were dreamt up without
our particular interests and hopes in
mind at points we need vigorously to
relearn the art of courage to remember
that the happiest lives have invariably
had inflection points where people did
the slightly unexpected and weird thing
took a gamble and won sometimes caution
is just weakness and cowardice wrapped
up in the cloak of self-deception
courage and caution need to fight this
one out without any presumption of
victory on either side any hard decision
we make will always by definition not be
perfect but with such thinking behind us
we have a slightly better chance than
usual of opting for the good enough joy
our videos are just the start of our
content we believe in making the world a
more emotionally intelligent place and
to that end we've now also published
some extraordinary books as well as
other merchandise that reinforces some
of the themes illustrated in our videos
please click on the link below to see
more